[Musica]
[Applauso]
nell'estate
1987 avevo quasi 34 anni la metà di
quelli che ho adesso e non ero mai stato
all'estero se non nel 1976 a montecarlo
con la 500 la mia prima auto
non ero mai andato in parigi o londra in
quel momento lì io ho deciso di cambiare
passo
e in due settimane ho fatto passaporto
ho visto turistico le valigie e sono
partito per il giappone lì per visitare
gli antichi templi lo si doveva fare a
piedi nudi
e il contatto l'esperienza del contatto
dei miei piedi con legno secolare delle
travi inserite nei pavimenti mi ha
trasmesso un'emozione
e un qualcosa che non ho più dimenticato
da lì in poi non vi ho cercato che il
legno venga bistrattato con delle varici
chimiche che lo snaturano
ho cominciato a sperimentare cere oli
vegetali
sapone o anche osato presentare dei
complementi d'arredo ingressi solamente
levigati perché volevo che più persone
possibili trovassero la gioia della cara
e fare toccare
sentire in legno nella sua forma
naturale
meglio se è caratterizzato dalla patina
del tempo
non ho più accettato che ci esistono vi
ho raccontato queste cose perché fa
parte del mio dna una delle
caratteristiche che ho notato che mi
appartengono
l'amore per il legno per la natura e
rifiuto per tutto ciò che è falso tutto
quello che vuole apparire quello che non
è
e poi sono arrivata io nel 2006 la
ricerca di un materiale naturale come il
legno ma innovativo come un degno che
addirittura si cuce porta luciano a
scoprire l'azienda di alberto
alberto è un signore eccezionale che ha
avuto il coraggio di inseguire un sogno
ha solo la quinta elementare ma il suo
ingegno e la sua profonda conoscenza la
sua profonda curiosità lo portano a
mettere a punto un processo innovativo
grazie al quale riesce a rendere
malleabile e addirittura
cucibile è imbattibile il tracciato di
legno io che incontrato alberto mi sono
licenziata in tronco per accompagnarlo
in questo suo sogno
conosco così luciano imprenditore che
esce dagli schemi che investe in ricerca
in bellezza e l'unicità e si rifiuta di
fare quello che fanno gli altri
le due aziende così realizzano insieme
dei prodotti eccezionali che vengono
anche esposti in una mostra alla
triennale di milano nel 2007
già il titolo surprising hood
preannunciava le opere di ingegno
sorprendenti che avremmo trovato lì
esposte come questa cintura in legno dei
dj
di nuovo i dati pazienza devo cercarmi
non farti avere l'attrezzatura godere
che si piega si può arrotolare si
possono dare
ed è anche cucita
la vita fa scivolare via velocemente gli
anni i tanti viaggi che adoro fare fin
da bambina mi fanno assaporare sempre
più bellezza
capisco che la bellezza e diversità e
che la diversità è ricchezza
e
laiche la natura i popoli e tutti i
paesi vanno proprio amati e rispettati
ognuno nella sua diversità ed è per
questo che adoro cambiare meta ogni ogni
anno proprio per la ricerca del bello e
del diverso ma c'è un'unica città alla
quale non mi stanco mai di tornare
venezia
questo luogo è in grado di trasmettermi
un'energia che sento come una grande
medicina in grado di alleviare momenti
anche più bui della mia vita mi aiuta a
superare anche la perdita prematura dei
miei genitori e da proprio nel 2011
quando muore mio padre che mi ritrovo ad
abbandonare il mondo del legno e del
design per prendere in mano l'attività
di famiglia
quello che non abbandono mai però è la
ricerca del bello l'amore per il bello e
quindi decido nel 2016 di visitare la
biennale di architettura di venezia
inaspettatamente luciano mi telefona e
mi propone di visitarle insieme
in quei giorni la mia vita privata e
rivoluzione e cominciava ad esserlo
anche quella professionale ricevo una
richiesta di un incarico da parte di un
imprenditore un investitore che aveva
accesso alle bricole sono quei pali che
sono immersi a gruppi di tre nella
laguna di venezia per segnalare i canali
navigabili
dalle imbarcazioni
ecco questo imprenditore voleva
trasformarla i mobili di design e vuole
datemi incaricati di seguire questa
impresa io mi sono rifiutato perché
precisando che esiste già è un'azienda
che i leader in questo settore che del
canada ma mi faceva queste questi questi
mobili queste cose
però questo rifiuto dell'incarico come
ha fatto scattare
alcune riflessioni
così ho cominciato a pensare che le
bricole non sono l'unico materiale che a
venezia viene scarpato viene cambiato
era bello si recuperarlo però era
sarebbe stato ghettizzante fare
un'azienda con un solo materiale così
comincia a pensare che murano con gli
scarti dei suoi vetri potrebbe essere
una miniera inesauribile
penso che i vaporetti cambiano
regolarmente le cime con le quali
attraccano e quindi comincio a pensare
di recuperare svariati pensi di venezia
qui penso anche che venezia è come tutti
sappiamo una città amata e desiderata
come meta turistica da tutti però i
turisti che arrivano non trovano
un'adeguata offerta di souvenir di
qualità materica ed estetica maria la
qualità della città che è fantastica
e quindi penso ai souvenir
e allora ricorda e lo dico anche fare
solo su venire e che ti sante e mi
immagino di aggiungere altri oggetti
utili alla persona da poter prendere
anche svincolati da venezia stessa mi
immagino anche di
caricarle di incaricare per i progetti
per il disegno di questo alla fine amici
design e arte avevo collezionato negli
anni e rimango molto meravigliato molto
sorpreso dall'entusiasmo con il quale
questi affermati professionisti carichi
di impegni di lavoro tra di loro
accettano immediatamente e con
entusiasmo di progettare per una startup
ancora sconosciuta
io sento parlare il giorno dopo giorno
luciano di questi pezzi che voleva
salvare trasformandoli in oggetti di
design è più lui ne parla più io mi
innamoro dell'uomo e dell'idea
[Applauso]
di venezia sono sempre stata innamorata
fin da piccola perché date le mie
origini image e tedesche e mezzi
comasche ogni qual volta arrivavano i
parenti da lontano la magia di venezia
era un dono dovuto da fare loro così si
partiva per questa città unica al mondo
per questa bolla sospesa nel tempo e lì
mi trovo ritrovai a ritornare sempre
anno dopo anno perché lì respiro
bellezza che non è sola la magia che
colgono i miei occhi
ma è soprattutto
la sensazione di benessere che questa
città mi mi lasciava
dopo
scusate vi sia di emozione
[Applauso]
praticamente respirare venezianità
eccellenza alto artigianato
mi fa star bene e di rientro a casa
vedevo anche i miei problemi come più
piccoli insomma sento parlare luciano
del progetto lo vedo nascere prendere
forma
e così cominciano a brillare gli occhi
sì perché luciano non stava solo
parlando di
produrre questi oggetti con un legno
cioè con un materiale che ambedue
amavamo molto in legno ma di recuperare
un legno esausto appunto questo delle
delle vecchie bricole che avevano
vissuto per anni nella laguna di venezia
e mi è sembrato meraviglioso proprio
perché potevamo produrre questi oggetti
senza tagliare gli alberi senza così
deforestare e senza quindi infliggere un
ulteriore ferita al nostro pianeta
così
diciamo torna
utilizzando questo legno scarto viene ri
donata una seconda vita
una seconda vita questi oggetti una
seconda chance
e poi
luciano aveva conosciuto gianluca
presidente della cooperativa sociale
futura e stava pensando di affidare è la
più parte delle lavorazioni proprio
questa realtà che reintegra nel mondo
del lavoro 60 ragazzi disagiati ragazzi
diversi o come preferisco chiamarli gli
unici
persone con svantaggio sociale o o
fisico
che
quindi
io che appartengo
[Risate]
il mio sostegno
a una cosa che mi tocca molto perché io
che appartengo al mondo di queste
persone meno fortunate per un problema
che ho fin dalla nascita
mi sento toccato nel profondo e così
guardo luciano e gli dico luciano devi
stare lasciare stare tutto il resto è da
qui che ti devi concentrare
comincio a pensare al nome da dare a
questa nuova attività
ed essendo venezia una città amata in
tutto il mondo a livello universale ho
pensato che doveva essere in inglese la
lingua straniera più conosciuto più
parlato nel mondo e quindi pezzi di
venezia che mi aveva inizialmente
ispirato diventa pieces of venice nasce
così una delle prime benefit company del
nord est d'italia sicuramente la prima
che si occupa di sostenibilità e di dvd
vivibilità di turismo consapevole che
faccio del bene ai veneziani ai turisti
e alle persone meno fortunate di noi
parte così la nostra avventura
imprenditoriale insieme nella vita e ora
anche nel lavoro luciano ed io però non
volevamo fare l'ennesima impresa che
guardasse solo al profitto ma
desideravamo perseguire l'obiettivo di
generare valore
mettendo al centro il benessere proprio
di territorio e di persone così creiamo
la squadra e decidiamo di circondarsi di
persone e realtà affini a noi con il
nostro stesso entusiasmo e che volessero
perseguire proprio questa via della
della sostenibilità
[Musica]
nascono così le collaborazioni più più
felici con persone in realtà che ad oggi
sostengono il progetto
la bellezza così come la intendiamo noi
volevamo proprio che facesse parte di
questa avventura imprenditoriale
e questo decidiamo di farlo proprio
circondandoci di persone
con i valori coni con i nostri valori
nel loro dna
inoltre questo progetto ci dava
l'occasione di mettere venezia al centro
dei nostri interessi esplorare la città
conoscere proprio da da vicino i suoi
luoghi i suoi abitanti
e così pensiamo anche che questa città
straordinaria che nasce dalle acque
ormai 1600 anni fa è permeata di primati
e di eccellenze riconosciute in tutto il
mondo luoghi pieni di storia di cultura
e di cultura e di arte così decidiamo di
raccontarli perché per noi la bellezza
era anche condivisione e condividere ci
rendiamo e ci rendeva felici
decidiamo così che i nomi dei nostri
oggetti dovevano essere sempre indirizzi
di venezia così da spingere gli amanti
della città oi turisti che ci
acquistavano i prodotti a fuoriuscire
dai classici percorsi che tutti quanti
noi conosciamo tipo rialto e san marco e
di andare alla scoperta proprio di una
venezia più autentica
volevamo condividere
quello che stavamo vivendo e scoprendo
noi da vecchie librerie a musei
ristoranti antiche farmacie chiese e
dipinti
insomma
volevamo che il nostro fosse anche un
progetto di trasmissione culturale
il progetto però mancava ancora qualcosa
mancava far diventare l'acquirente parte
attiva conca ring incontriamo nicola il
presidente della onlus magini inizio
letti un'associazione che mette al
centro la cura del territorio della
città
l'essere sempre in ordine la città
questi ragazzi nel loro tempo
istituiscono delle giornate di pulizia
dalla liberano la città dai graffiti e
dalla plastica soprattutto ecco che
abbiamo trovato il nostro anello ma
colmar mancate decidiamo così di donare
a quest'associazione una parte dei
nostri potenti un nostro modo per dire
grazie alla città e restituirle parte
del tanto che ci stava tornando
si e poi c'erano i segnali le
coincidenze tutto portava a venezia
quando nel 2017 nasce il nostro progetto
avevamo appena acquistato casa e sapete
dove siamo andati ad abitare
beh nell'abitazione che fu dei
discendenti di un doge veneziano il
sessantasettesimo per l'esattezza il
doge cristofaro moro e così quando i
nostri vicini di casa francesco
gabriella c ce lo raccontarono e come
benvenuto ci regalarono un piatto con lo
stemma dogale della famiglia moro
beh ci vennero si vennero i brividi e
così seguivamo un più un flusso di
eventi incontri e tutto quanto ci
portava venezia un altro incontro
fortunato ad esempio stato quello con
alberto toso fei che è uno scrittore
saggista è un profondo conoscitore
proprio di venezia dei suoi misteri
delle leggende dei luoghi
beh insomma alberto quando quando lo
abbiamo contattato conosceva già il
nostro progetto e ne era rimasto colpito
così è salito a bordo con noi pieno di
entusiasmo e ha oggi è il nostro il
narratore ufficiale della nostra realtà
e ci sta aiutando proprio con lo
storytelling così da
rafforzare proprio questo obiettivo che
avevamo di trasmissione culturale
insomma seguendo questo percorso di di
bellezza di passione sono arrivate tante
soddisfazioni tra cui anche quella di
essere annoverati tra i green cross gli
eroi verdi di alessandro gassman il noto
attore e regista negli ultimi anni è
diventato anche un
attivista impegnato nella lotta contro i
cambiamenti climatici
e quindi lui ha deciso di scrivere un
libro perché ha raccolto tante storie di
imprese come la nostra che hanno messo
al centro il recupero e il benessere del
territorio delle persone e con questo
libro lui racconta proprio di un'italia
che si impegna che non rimane ferma a
guardare ma con un diverso modo di fare
impresa
ci dimostra che le soluzioni ai tanti
problemi ambientali già ci sono
c'è ad esempio chi mette appunto dei
materiali edili che derivano dallo
scarto del riso così si possono
costruire delle case a impatto zero che
non hanno bisogno né di essere
riscaldate né di essere raffreddate
oppure c'è chi mette a punto delle
pitture con lo scarto dello yogurt
pitture che sono in grado di assorbire
l'inquinamento e addirittura
neutralizzano il covip
aziende agricole che producono
rispettando i tempi della natura creando
economia circolare a emissioni zero
insomma
si può avere molta soddisfazione e anche
ritorno economico e con tanto entusiasmo
il libro di gassman questo ce lo
dimostra ed è quello che vorremmo anche
noi oggi che siamo qui su questo palco e
dirvi che insieme si può si può
se tutti insieme perseguiamo questa
questa strada di bellezza di
sostenibilità di cura per
l'ambiente per le persone un mondo
migliore è possibile
il segreto è di avere una visione a
lungo termine
e non girarsi dall'altra parte e non
coltivare sempre questa
questa cultura dell'indifferenza
ma iniziare ad agire perché insieme si
può fare
a quanti si chiedono cosa è per noi la
soste vivibilità noi disegni carine dio
rispondiamo che mettere al centro delle
proprie azioni anche
imprenditoriali la cura e il benessere
delle persone e del territorio
perché un mondo sostenibile e vivibile
fatto di bellezza e rispetto e possibile
concludo con un ricordo che risale al
iniziato parlando dell 87 comunque
concludo con un discorrere con un
ricordo che risale a due anni prima
quando un avvocato tedesco mi disse
luciano ricco orba se vuoi puoi e vista
la mia faccia perplessa continua dicendo
mi si luciano prova a dirmi qualcosa che
realmente hai voluto e non hai potuto
fare
ma deve realmente a farlo ho voluto
bene dal 1985 ho cominciato a fare sogni
realizzabili
insomma se avete un sogno osate se
volete un mondo migliore impegnatevi e
se volete essere felici fate ciò che vi
appassiona è che vi fa star bene e state
attenti ai segnali cogliete li eseguite
il flusso e abbiate anche un po di
incoscienza nel buttarvi e anche se
tutti quanti dicono che è da folli fare
la cosa che vi appassiona e che vi fa
star bene porta sempre con sé una grande
bellezza grazie
[Applauso]